[Music]
we're going right now we're rushing over
to
the game to do the ball game we're doing
a baseball game
my grandfather was a cardinals fan he
died from cigarette smoke
but
but he also liked the cardinals did he
like
the win he like winston's and the
cardinals bro so praise god dude
uh
yeah so we're heading over to throw out
the first pitch right now and then we're
gonna bust back over and get the um
and get on stage and do the first show
what's up players
gang baby
i love you bro be good gang baby
we're pulling up down here to bush
stadium i came here in 19
i came here in 2007 dude one time
a friend of mine had got chicken pox
adult chicken box and we still came dude
and we had to ice him down and
everything i remember
borrowing a bag of ice from the vending
people and
icing his ass down he had a hot take on
that's it baby
got that cards brown
what you guys doing going to the game
yeah i'm throwing the first pitch out at
the baseball game are you actually yeah
okay okay hey ladies
we got the jersey right here daddy
let's go dude
[Music]
still more pitches than clevenger has on
the mound this year baby let's go
go cordrays
[Music]
dude that was awesome nice clean grass
you don't get that anymore
dude our ball field growing up had a
damn uh
grave site a little somebody died out
there and they just didn't
small tomb though they had done it out
of i think quick creep
[Music]
do a little too much huh
but too much mikey on
that smoke baby
[Applause]
you